Lea Michele she has generated a lot of
backlash this week with some co-star
saying their experience of working with
Lea was anything but gleeful pure legend
well that's not the general opinion
these dates but thank you it all started
when Lea tweeted her support of the
black lives matter movement co-star
Samantha Murray where's response
accusing Lea of making her first
television gig a living hell her tweet I
believe you told everyone that if you
had the opportunity you would bleep in
my wig what followed was a social media
storm and Glee co-stars speaking out I
am NOT going to say that Lea Michele is
racist that's not what I'm saying
we've already seen other people say that
it was not the most comfortable
environment Heather Morris tweeted was
she unpleasant to work with very much so
I'd rather have like a smaller amount of
really quality friends than a hundred
you know people that are like half
friends and you are looking well thank
you now if you'll excuse me I'll make my
way to the back of the bus within 18
hours Michele was fired from her
spokesperson post with hellofresh Lea
scream queens co-stars ariana grande &
Keke Palmer also unfollowed her on
Instagram
but it's not the first time Michelle's
been called out Naya Rivera wrote about
their strained relationship in her 2016
memoir is Denton and Rachel hated each
other but they also had like this
love-hate sort of relationship and I
feel like that's what Lee and I had
while we were on the show you did
document a couple times where you felt
like she was unprofessional definitely
on the same definitely they could tell
you many good Lea who was expecting her
first child in the fall eventually
issued an apology that some called too
little too late
she says the backlash has made her quote
focused specifically on how my own
behavior towards fellow cast members was
perceived by them the greatest thing
about Glee was it taught everyone should
just be proud of what they look like and
who they are and what they want to be
and that's what always made me so proud
to be on Glee and XG missed
[Music]